let's say we have some function f F and
it's a mapping from the set X to Y so if
I were to draw the set X right there
that's my set X and then if I were to
draw the set Y just like that we know
and I've done this several videos ago
that a function just associates any
member of our set X so I have some
member of my set X there if I apply the
function to it or if we're dealing with
vectors we could imagine instead of
using the word function we would use the
word transformation but it's the same
thing we would associate with this
element or this member of X a member of
Y so that's why we call it a mapping it
says hey that guy when I apply this
function we're doing a different color
this little member right there is
associated this little member of X is
associated with this member of Y and you
would have if this is right here this is
a capital X so let's say we call let me
just let's say we call this a and let's
call that B and we would say that the
function where a is a member of X and B
is a member of Y we would say that F of
a is equal to B this is all a review of
everything that we've learned already
about functions now I'm going to define
a couple of interesting functions the
first one I guess it's really just one
function I said it's a couple but I'll
call it the identity function identity
the identity function and this is a
functional this is called a big capital
I and it's identity function operates on
some set so let's say this is the
identity function on set X and it's a
mapping from X to X and what's
interesting about the identity function
is that if you give it some a that is a
member of X so let's say you give it
that a the identity function applied to
that member of X so the identity
function of a is going to be equal to a
so it literally just Maps
things back to itself so the identity
function if I were to draw it on this
diagram right here would look like this
it would look like when we pick a nice
suitable color it would look like this
we just kind of be a circle it just
points back at the point that you start
off with associates all points with
themselves that's the identity function
on X if a is pointed as it applies to
the point a if you apply it to some
other point in X we it would just refer
back to itself now that's the identity
function on X you could also have an
identity function on Y so let's say that
B is a member of Y so I do B right there
then the Y identity function so this
would be the identity function on Y
applied to B we'll just refer back to
itself it would just refer back to
itself and so that would be equal to B
this is the identity function on Y and
so you might say hey Sal these are kind
of silly functions but we'll use them
they're actually a at least a useful
notation to use as we kind of progress
through our explorations of linear
algebra but I'm going to make a new
definition I'm going to say that a
function a function let me pick a nice
color pink I'm going to say that a
function or let me say F since we
already established it right over here
I'm going to say that F is invertible
invertible introducing some new
terminology f is invertible if and only
if the following is true so if and only
if the following is true I could either
write it with this two-way arrows like
that or I could write it as if with two
F's that means that if this is true then
this is true and only if this is true
and so this implies that and that
implies this so f is invertible I'm kind
of making a definition right here if and
only if there exists there exists a
function a function we'll call it will
allow I'll call it nothing just yet I'll
call it something in a second
alright it is this F with this negative
one superscript on it so f is invertible
if and only if there exists a function f
inverse well I guess I just called it
something F inverse such that such that
let me do that in purple such that if I
apply F if I apply F remember F is just
a mapping from X to Y so let me redo it
so this function f inverse is going to
be a mapping from Y to X so I'm saying
that F is invertible if there exists a
function f inverse that's a mapping from
Y to X such that if I apply if I take
the composition if I take the
composition of F inverse with F this is
equal to the identity the identity
function over X so let's think about
what's happening this is just part of it
actually let me just complete the whole
definition this is true this has to be
true and F the composition of F with the
identity function has to be equally the
composition of F with the inverse
function has to be equal to the identity
function over Y so let's think about
what's this saying there's some function
f we'll just call it
well I'll call it right now this is
called the inverse of F this is the
inverse the inverse of F and it's a
mapping from Y to X so f was a mapping
from let me draw it up here so f is a
mapping from X to Y we showed that this
is the mapping of F right there it goes
in that direction we're saying there has
to be some other function f inverse
that's a mapping from Y to X so let's
write it here so f inverse is a mapping
from Y is a mapping from Y to X so f
inverse if you give me some value and
set Y I go to set X so this guy's domain
is this guy is codomain and this guy's
Co domain is this guy's domain fair
enough but let's see what it's saying
it's saying that the composition of F
inverse with F has to be equal the
identity matrix so essentially it's
saying if I apply F to some value in X
right if you think about what what's
this composition doing this guy is going
from X to Y and then this guy goes from
Y to X right so let's think about what's
happening here F F is going from X to Y
and then F inverse is going from Y to X
so this composition is going to be a
mapping from X to X which the identity
matrix or the identity identity function
needs to do it needs to go from X to X
and they're saying this equals the
identity function so that means when you
apply F on some value in our domain so
you go here and then you apply f inverse
to that point over there you go back to
this original point so another way of
saying this another way of saying this
right here is that F let me do it in
another color
that F inverse the composition of F
inverse with F of some member of X of
the set X is equal to is equal to the
identity function applied on that item
this is what this these two statements
are equivalent and so the ID by
definition this thing is going to be
your original thing or another way of
writing this is that F inverse applied
to F of a is going to be equal to a
that's what this first statement tells
us and if you think of it visually it's
saying you start with an A you apply F
to it and you get this value right here
that is f of a I'm saying it equals B or
I set it equal to B earlier on but then
if you apply this F inverse and I
doesn't always exist but if you apply
that F inverse to this function it needs
to go back to this by definition it
needs to go back to original a it has to
be equal has to be equivalent to just
doing this little closed loop right here
when I introduce you to the identity
function
now that's what this statement is
telling us right here the second
statement is saying look if I apply F to
F inverse I'm getting the identity
function on Y so if I start at some
point in Y right there and I apply F
inverse first if I apply F inverse maybe
I go right here
maybe this point let's call that
lowercase Y so this would be F inverse
of lowercase Y and then if I were to
apply F to that I know this is getting
this chart is getting very confusing if
I apply F to this right here I need to
go right back to my original Y so this
when I apply F to F inverse of Y this
has to be equivalent of just doing the
identity function on Y so that's what
the second statement is saying or
another way to write it is that F of F
inverse of let's say of Y where Y is a
member of the set capital y it has to be
equal to Y and you've been exposed the
idea of an inverse before we're just
doing it a little bit more precisely
because we're where we're going to start
dealing with these notions with
transformations and matrices in the very
near future so it's good to be exposed
to it in this kind of more precise form
now the first thing you might ask is hey
let's say that I have a function f let's
say I have a function f and it does have
there does exist a function f inverse
that satisfies these two these two
requirements so f is invertible f is
invertible
the obvious question or maybe it's not
an obvious question is is is f inverse
unique and you actually probably the
obvious question is how do you know when
something is invertible and we're going
to talk a lot about that in the very
near future but let's say we know that f
is invertible how do we know or do we
know whether f inverse is unique and to
answer that question to answer that
question let's assume it's not unique so
if it's not unique let's say that
there's two functions that satisfy our
two
range that that can act as inverse
functions of f so let's say that G is
one of them so let's say G is a mapping
remember F is a mapping from X to Y
let's say that G is a mapping from Y to
X such that if I apply F to something if
I apply F to something and then apply G
to it so this gets me from X to Y and
then when I do the composition with G
that gets me back into X this is
equivalent this is equivalent to the
identity function this was this was part
of the definition of what it means to be
an inverse so I'm saying that G is an
inverse of I'm assuming that G is an
inverse of F this assumption implies
these two things that assumption applies
those two things now let's say that H is
another inverse let's say that H is
another inverse of F H is another
inverse by definition by what I just
called an inverse H has to satisfy two
requirements has to be a mapping from Y
to X and then if I take the composition
of H with F I have to get the identity
matrix on the set X now that wasn't just
part of the definition it implies even
more than that if something is an
inverse has to satisfy both of these the
inverse the composition of the inverse
with the function has to become the
identity matrix on X and then the
composition of the function with the
inverse has to be identity matrix sorry
the identity function on Y so let's
write that so G is an inverse of F it
applies this and it also implies it also
implies I'll do it in yellow that the
composition of F with G is equal to the
identity matrix so I keep saying matrix
the identity function on Y and if we do
it with H the fact that H is an inverse
of F implies that the composition of F
with H is equal to the identity function
unwise as well and just as Roman let me
redraw what I drew at the beginning just
so we know what we're doing so if this
is the set X right here let me do it in
different color let's say this right
here is the set Y we know that F is a
mapping from X to Y we know that F is a
mapping from X to Y what we're seeing is
what we're trying to determine is is f
inverse unique so any inverse so we're
saying that G is a situation that if you
take the composition of G with F you get
the identity matrix so f does that if
you could take G if you take G you're
going to go back to the same point so
it's equivalent so taking the
conversation of G with F that means
doing F first then G this is equivalent
this is equivalent of just taking the
identity function in X so just taking an
X and going back to an X it's equivalent
to that so this is G right here and the
same thing is true with H H should also
be if I start with some element in X and
go into Y and then apply H and then
apply H like that it should also be
equivalent to the identity
transformation that's what this
statement and this statement are saying
now this statement is saying that if I
start with some entry in Y here and I
apply G which is the inverse of F I'm
going to go here
so G will take me there and that when I
apply F then to that so then when I
apply my F to that I'm going to go back
to that same element of Y and that's
equivalent to just doing the identity
function on Y so that's the same thing
as the identity function of Y and I
could do the same thing here with H just
take a point here apply H then apply F
back I should just go back to that point
that's all of what this is saying so
let's go back to the question of whether
G is unique are these can we have two
different inverse functions G and H so
let's start with G remember G is just a
mapping from Y to X so this is going to
be equal to
this is the same thing as the
composition of the identity function
over X with G to show you why that's the
case remember G just goes from let me
all these diagrams get confused very
quickly so let's say this is X and this
is y remember G is a mapping from X to
from Y to X so G will take us there is a
mapping from Y to X and I'm saying that
this G is equivalent to the identity
mapping or the identity function in
composition with this because all this
is saying is you apply G and then you
apply the identity mapping on X so
obviously you're going to get to the
exact same mapping or the exact same
point so these are equivalent but what
is another way of writing the identity
mapping on X what's another way of
writing that well by definition if H is
another inverse of F this is true so I
can replace this in this expression with
a composition of H with F so this is
going to be equal to the composition of
H with F and the composition of that
with G and you might want to put
parentheses here actually I'll do it
very lightly you might want to put
parentheses there but I showed you a
couple of videos ago that the
composition of functions or of
transformations is associative it
doesn't matter if you put the
parentheses there or if you put the
parentheses there actually I'll do that
I'll put the parentheses there at first
just so you can understand that this
this is the same thing as that right
there but we know that composition is
associated so this is equal to the
composition of H with the composition of
F and G now what is this equal to
the composition of F and G well it's
equal to by definition it's equal to the
identity transformation over Y so this
is equal to this is equal to H composed
with of the composition of H with the
identity function over Y with this right
here now what is this going to be
remember H is a function is a mapping
from Y to X so let me redraw it so
that's my X and that is my Y
take some element in why and gives me
some element in X now if I take the
composition of well let me take it if I
take the composition of the identity and
Y so that's essentially I take some
element let me do it this way I take
some element in Y I apply the identity
function which essentially just gives me
that element again and then I apply H to
that that's the same thing as just just
applying H to the function to begin with
to begin with so just going through this
little exercise we've shown even though
we've started off saying I have these
two different inverses we've just shown
that G must be equal to H so any
function has a unique inverse you can't
set up two different inverses and you'll
if you do you'll find that they're
always going to be equal to each other
so so far we know what an inverse is and
we know and we don't know what causes
someone to be able to have an inverse or
not but we know if they have an inverse
how to think about it and we also know
that that inverse we also know that that
inverse is unique